good evening pastor thank you for
everything have a question concerning
our communion services it looks like
things have been changing all right
how i was
brought up in or when i came into the
church i was taught that i think when
having convenient service the morning
part of the service you know you the
pastor preaches a sermon concerning the
last supper
and then you wash feet
then you come and and come on partake of
right service
and then when you leave you know the the
left
singing him right right
um
what i've seen or what was tried to
that was um try to be implemented was
everything done be done in the morning
part the washington field and then
preach the sermon and then have
benediction
and leave
so i stated you know about how i
understood it and mark and then you
leave yes when do you partake of the
emblems yes sir and then you sing and
then we leave uh
after the hymn we sung and we leave
singing
so i don't know what's what's your take
on i'm i i didn't catch the difference
though i didn't catch the difference oh
sorry
you said the new thing you're seeing is
what oh well the new thing they they
switch it around so instead of having
everything in the evening sorry the
washing off the field after after the
sermon they want to do everything
the washing off the feet the communion
service first and then they'll purchase
a sermon
and then
have a
do a benediction to close the service
so is that
also
accepted
oh no feed washing
no no he's saying
that the preaching came after the
communion oh i see i see i see i see
that there's no biblical mandate for
when the preaching should come
it's a matter of style and preference
the preaching can come anywhere
yeah can come anywhere um it doesn't
have to be before the emblems or after
it depends on what the people prefer yes
it's a choice it's a choice i mean you
look at every church their list of all
preliminaries they vary from church to
church i've been to churches to preach i
had to wait 90 minutes before i spoke
there were 90 minutes of preliminaries
and maybe the church baptized five
people in 40 years but they have 90
minutes of preliminaries are you
following me and i can understand it but
anyway it's a personal choice it's a
personal choice yes yes
for instance you have offering am i
first right then you have what a morning
prayer or whatever you can switch that
around now it accepts people
you have morning pray before the
offering some people get very upset if
you change the order of service
but order of service is not a biblical
mandate it depends on the individual
church